and what i can tell you this morning is
that as a result firstly of the
information
provided by the cabinet office inquiry
team
and secondly my officer's own assessment
i can confirm
that the met is now investigating
a number of events that took place at
downing street and whitehall
in the last two years
in relation to potential breaches of
covet 19 regulations
my officers have assessed several other
events
that appear to have taken place at
downing street and whitehall
on the available information
these other events
are assessed as not reaching the
threshold for criminal investigation
throughout the pandemic the met has
sought to take as i have said a
proportionate approach
i should stress that the fact that we
are now investigating does not of course
mean
that fixed penalty notices will
necessarily be issued in every instance
and to every person involved
we will not be giving a running
commentary
on our current investigations
but i can assure you that we will give
updates at significant points
as we would generally do
and finally i would just say
you mentioned a number of other matters
that you are clearly frustrated about
and no doubt some other people as well
i know
uh what you are talking about in each
instance i suspect it's not worth
discussing them here and not appropriate
all i would say is i beg to differ
i
am fully aware of the decisions that
were made in each of the cases that you
mentioned uh omesh
and i believe we did the right thing and
we will always seek to do the right
thing